Олексій Гончаренко - європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі Ми зараз
розриваємо договори з Росією щодо
Чорного моря щодо Азовського моря
абсолютно правильний крок там собі Путін
щось оголошує Азовське море наше
внутрішнє От тобі Азовське море От тобі
Чорне море От тобі Україна Чорне море ще
всміхнеться це буде наша перемога це
наше море по ньому будуть наші кораблі
ходити Я хочу нагадати як ще нещодавно
На жаль навіть в нашій країні заводилися
справи за керченську протоку коли
українські кораблі з українською Одеси в
українській Маріуполь йшли українською
керченською протокою це було не може
бути воно було українське воно є воно
обов'язково буде сьогодні ми маємо перед
Всім світом ставити це питання про Чорне
море бо Путін намагається закрити часів
ще давніх
античних греків Чорне море цього
годівниця вільного світу і сьогодні весь
світ відчув коли Путін закрив Чорне море
що це таке які жахливі наслідки по
всьому світу тож друзі наше завдання
відкрити Чорне море наше завдання щоб ви
знов кораблі йшли з Одеси в Одесу зерном
з металом з усім іншим необхідним для
всього світу тому що Чорне море - це
життєво важливий напрямок і путінська це
спробу атакувати Чорне море
судноплавство ми безумовно маємо
зупинити ми це зупинимо Слава
військово-морським силам України хочу
нагадати як ракетне крейсер Москва вже
перетворився в підводний човен те саме
буде з усім чорноморським флотом Росії
Він має бути знищений Слава збройним
силам України сьогодні 366 лютого але
перемога Буде за нами